hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Arianna
ba Suri today I'm checking out a video
called Tyrone Magnus and Ryan right
answer questions number two I saw the
first one that Tyrone did it in your
reaction to it but it was Tyrone Magnus
answers questions this time it's time
Rho Magnus and Ryan right now I'm
interested
so thanks Rick field for including me
yeah she she's kind of racist and
doesn't like that I wrote not true I'm
just kidding she loves black hawk oh
here we go before we start I just want
to say this is only for laughs Tyrone
and only likes ladies you guys ready
wait till it see what I'm gonna do come
on you can't just spring that yeah again
how biggest I roads [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] huge send me a photo he's
[ __ ] huge so this is what's happening
my son some-some of [ __ ] Tyrone
Magnus is staying here for a while
because well I burn apartment out I
wanted to do its get crash here for a
while I thought I got a new roommate
right now you have this huge [ __ ]
doctor here's what we're gonna do okay I
am gonna go in there Nikki might be a
little flattered I mean look at this
thing
you're like damn that should be hot why
do you want Tyrone Meg I like the guy
big black guy 620 it's basically you got
a big [ __ ] your [ __ ] buff your black
[ __ ] beautiful to look at how can you
watch this Tim like I'll get excited but
when I'm around Magnus you like I might
comes out and even more you never saw
this video babe Tyrone all seriousness
do you really want Ryan right yeah what
do you know wanna be Tyrone's
two per kilo see he's like my teddy bear
might be like Papa Bear I'm ready to go
I already go now wow that's got a really
oh wait
sup big wow this guy like knows our
channels oh no he doesn't really simply
properties any dick pics
he does they're awesome its he's [ __ ]
he's like 15 inches he's never been able
to have sex because the second a woman
sees it they just they die they have
they die it's also a bright black [ __ ]
it's like glimmers it's kind of like
Edward Cullen when he's in the Sun but
instead it with his penis it looks like
you know it's like diamonds diamonds
diamonds in the sky Kanye but you
haven't seen it I've seen it I've seen
it
sometimes it sends me a picture of his
butthole I'm like Tyrone send me a
picture of your butthole and I'll be
like yeah I'm like Tyrone I want to wear
a strap-on [ __ ] you and then he's like
why would you wear a strap-on I'm like
because your ass deserves a bigger [ __ ]
than what I have to offer it's very
thoughtful
I love Tyrone anyway a Rick field it's
is kind of honorable that he like and
knows our channel so well like he was
using footage from different videos and
he knew how to put it together oh yeah
that video finally got it hey if you
guys haven't seen that video it's called
Alyssa fools day the video is titled
April Fool's prank you can find it on
the channel it finally got an age
restriction video after a year and a
half all right yeah because it goes
crazier than what I just did there goes
crazier yeah like you should check it
out sometime if you want to get a good
idea of my sense of humor when I'm
single that was a pretty Veronica
but Osprey Veronica I pre came to the
thought of Veronica all the time then I
came and now she's my girlfriend I love
Ariana one day your channel is gonna get
so big that someone's gonna do this for
you do some compilation video
compilation videos you get ready catch
already on on compilation videos xvideos
comm she has her own compilation videos
they're actually called compilation
videos I don't know why I do this to you
I'm [ __ ] over it
you should be that's right I make money
at least saves jobs you'd be a great
porn star I'd be a terrible point sorry
I know it no you'd be a really good one
I wouldn't I'm super lazy anyway thank
you guys for tuning in to the reject
channel if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can check out Ariana's channel a lot of
fun stuff coming on there already has
two videos to hold videos like 10 hours
a day and there's gonna be one hopefully
per other month two weeks two in two
weeks
Wow you false on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where if we get enough followers
we can get product placement people
Ariana is okay Ariana can you remove the
black shirt for a second so Ariana for
product placement ariana is hoping to
get breast reduction surgery actually no
what did I ever tell you yeah no yeah no
this is an infomercial now what what
happened no I went for an appointment
for breast reduction why would you do
that to any man that ever wants you ever
yeah I mean still shocking to all of
your people but I have more to offer
than than that oh I only do this to get
more twitter follow yeah yeah at least
the church goes up subscriber alright to
video channel breast reduction